your son is a journalist right yes yes
very easy now we just got word and he's
been kidnapped in Syria they reached out
that means my son is still alive it's
illegal to pay ransom and you won't risk
sending your people in to help what are
you going to do that information is
classified
do you think I'm afraid of a jail
sentence
everyone who assists you you'll send
them to jail I know the government won't
help you but there is someone else I'm
here because I want to bring you Indy
home we have our own Network there's
only one thing these [ __ ] respond to
and it's money you can't expect me to
raise twenty million dollars we can
connect you with people to the safe
return of your son the money that we've
raised is going through a 15 of our
friends who are going to drive it to the
drop-off point you have to deal with the
consequences of your decision
so do you scrape together enough money
to spread around some Middle Eastern
bribery Network you just decide just
swallow the awful [ __ ]
that maybe you could have done something
more it's been three months maybe I
should take things into my own hands
be careful with that we need to buy a
little more time you need to go public
and we need to do it now the owner of
the Hawks he wants to speak to you
personally
he gave us $800,000
please don't hurt my son
[Music]
you